kudos bomb man I'm so full right now I
can breathe house is my favorite [ __ ]
place - I do like all the basic stock
really well it's like nothing like
really special about them like nobody
really coming for a specific niche but
no I mean it's it's like this is all you
need I mean for me I just need a good
bowl of ha good like vermicelli Bowl or
like some good spring rolls and good egg
rolls and I'm good y'all so like I
actually saw that video that you didn't
yeah yo I just want to say bro like I
really didn't mean to offend you like I
wasn't trying to make you feel bad about
you know what you do for living and know
what your path is but to be honest man
like I was just saying how I saw it
and I just felt like I mean that's like
a half-ass applause well I mean I don't
know man like that wasn't my intention
that was my such a bomb though if you
don't like for me like I'm not like
trying to say anything
perspective I saw and I saw it was dated
like you know these people on camera may
not see you know everything that we do
but you know for the past four five
years that I know you every time you
bring up something that I do you kind of
talk down to like it's not over you know
and at the end of the day you don't know
how are living so when you come at me
like that I have to think to myself okay
number one I get my I'll be upset about
this or it doesn't have the best
intentions uh-huh and so for me I give
you the benefit I know it's your guys
intention I ain't got the sugars for
reports like you always have to sit up
one little thing under your breath about
what I'm doing and I don't make the same
comment about what you're doing okay
that's fair that's fair but I just feel
like I'd be doing you a disservice if I
didn't say what I felt if I feel a
certain way if I feel certain like and
and I don't say it how are we friends
because that means that I'm just I'm
just like a yes-man and just saying what
you won here and to be honest and like
yeah I don't see what you do day to day
I just feel like you've got a lot of
Susman and you see me like busting ass
and going out here and and trying to
like prove myself every day and doing
these jobs no dude I just thought
this way there's a profession right
y'all so like yeah like oh say man like
dude I got a lot of real life experience
like but you can't deny the fact that
I've done these certain projects and I
have taken away something from every one
of those things and I'm just trying to
tell you how I see it in I see the
passion about this like you always talk
about what you've done
actually no that's because dude David
no that's because I have to talk about
what I'm doing to tell you what what the
experiences were so that you can [ __ ]
learn from it or something man because I
always bring up what you're doing it's
like you're trying to do this
dick-measuring contest and I think
obviously I go I'm just trying to tell
you that what I do is just as valid as
or do we have done self like in your
time like I said I respected Pat I just
want you to respect my craft too because
the line was also working okay it's
legit okay you know what I mean but
you've been by your your spectrum is is
in this insular world right you're at
your house
doing these videos and stuff but you're
not really yeah you're putting yourself
out on the internet but like are you
getting in front of physical people and
putting you're putting a pride online a
bit like your insecurities and all that
stuff for people to judge when how long
how long ago Zac but that it's not even
how long I've done that for nearly ten
years to life but that I decided to do
it for a - enough for you like your
audience is like this playing you know
whatever these casting directors
fine I'm not but see that's that's
popular you know David David David no no
without photo David
realize it if I choose money around me
just about that I really want to go
there's a bigger consequences hits and
that's to me that's a hard push to do
because these are the people that we get
to where I am right now and I
all right that's that's okay okay so you
think okay let me let me let me let me
play double that game don't you feel
obligated to your fans you know to
explore the options as well and give
them what they but that's what I'm
saying is you're not pushing your
[ __ ] self and you just like in your
comfortable action you get to the same
thing and what are you doing okay I
don't know if he's I don't I don't see
what you do every day
exactly that's exactly what you don't
see what I do okay
but see that's the same thing well
that's what that's what I'm saying I
don't even see it I don't see the
product of how you're growing so I'm not
seeing where that that's panning out
where what's the difference between now
and three years ago with what you were
doing 1.3 million subscribers that's
okay that's great that's great
but then one see it says this is the
issue right now see you're a [ __ ]
your discontent over
does it look I'm happy with the way I
dude I'm having I like pursuing other
stuff outside of it which is why I come
to talk about your suit yah yah I still
I think you have a misconception well
not my thing I'm asking what I don't do
that
yes do you know what David I never said
I was an amazing actor I'm still [ __ ]
learning yeah I'm still a [ __ ]
student do okay I get that to the soul
you know I'm still learning my family I
still doing what I have got here then
don't [ __ ] David there don't [ __ ]
come to me and tell me when I'm [ __ ]
vain after and then not [ __ ] do
anything odd because [ __ ] annoying
you see I'm not doing happy do you want
that's a [ __ ] to 8 knots and and I think
I think you have misconception about I
don't
no David
I say those things because I'm so
invested in what I do so like those
balls I'm investing that stuff it means
a lot to me see like where is that for
you where you're like if I don't if I
don't do this then do [ __ ] talk to me
about - then [ __ ] you listen they don't
[ __ ] ask me for advice - well if
you're gonna ask mr. [ __ ] that thing in
your son - I don't know because I'm not
a Dane well then if you're gonna ask me
you tell me I don't take anything
because absolutely but in case young
then where the [ __ ] is that
that's where the [ __ ] is the [ __ ] you
don't know [ __ ] [ __ ] auditions dude
that's [ __ ] funny because I
what I don't function on the stuff that
I feel that like that's not this [ __ ]
part of it David of course is a part of
the but what I'm saying is is that I'm
going to my route that's [ __ ] yeah
like the [ __ ] is the [ __ ] [ __ ]
milling the [ __ ] know any around yeah
you got different opportunities that I
do you're a seasoned actor no I thought
can work on our way
yes you I'm telling you about
have you seen the little bit pissed off
for some [ __ ] reason which I guess I
am [ __ ] pissed on dealers don't do
that I don't understand doctor be so
[ __ ] listening this is why
conversations fire [ __ ] the creek about
it first before I talk you do whatever
is you because you got this [ __ ]
tender you're aren't you a [ __ ]
process I'm your [ __ ] process no I
don't know [ __ ] chill out is why I
don't get talking about this UI Parral
I'll [ __ ] cottage now how do you
think [ __ ] car scene by [ __ ] watch
who dude what the [ __ ] bro
I don't know it's gonna get the [ __ ] is
your problem dude no just take me
[ __ ] on [ __ ] take me home
no but seriously what do you what do you
want me to do with you what do you want
I gotta say is dude just don't [ __ ]
ask me for advice that's it done I'm
[ __ ] over it that's funny because
you're the one who told me to come to
you for [ __ ] advice yo just [ __ ]
take me home I'm over it dude I'm over
it
I meant your [ __ ] husband's out of
his [ __ ] mind